he has always been one of those guys who
a highlight film in transition suits to
three very well how about cp3 watch that
battle you talk about vista klutz when
you look him up in the dictionary it's a
picture of him because he is the mr.
clutch the NPA coming off a three and OH
sweep of the East Coast
big defensive play down to stop the
intruder the closeout that game against
the Celtics well the first two games
between these teams were in Utah the
Thunder in the final eight team will
play you saw two more times that both of
those will be here in Oklahoma City
you see officials conferring them here
prior to the start of this game and
Blake conference here trying to get
something worked out Chris Paul went in
poked his head in to try to get a little
infant a little more information you
know when you talk about the Jazz you
got to talk about you know how do you
stop him his defense on Mitchell is
gonna be really important tonight Chris
Paul and then being able now that they
don't have the services of Rudy Gobert
how does that change well he's the
number one guy in the NBA had screen
assists you know situations where he
sets a screen and he's getting assists
because he set the screen and somebody
scored now that guy's not here tonight
Rudy Gobert he's out with an illness so
that changes the dynamics for the Jazz
now if you're the Thunder you're saying
alright well you know what we can attack
that paint down cuz you know co-vary
he's went back-to-back Defensive Player
of the Year and that's gonna be pretty
pretty special in itself not having a
ball to floor so now Rudy Gobert but the
Thunder will get shaken dis Alexander
back
[Music]
so Gobert is out to see both head
coaches now talking with the officials -
in Schneider and Billy Donovan's we
don't know what they're talking about
and until we do we can't report anything
but clearly the officials talking with
both head coaches
[Music]
laters
wit food starting lamps went through
warmups were complaining to take the
court but clearly a conversation going
on here between the officials and both
head coaches
[Music]
[Applause]
like we've been ready we're ready cuz
it's been ready for a couple days for
this one three old sweep bit momentum
here nice crowd here tonight folks
glad you join us as well then of course
coming off of that fun road trip take it
down Detroit New York and Boston had a
couple of days off Monday and Tuesday
plenty of time to recover to get ready
for this big matchup with the Jazz
obviously aware that no team stacked up
in the Western Conference
[Music]
still the discussion ongoing here then
tailor mark Lindsay that far the crew
chief talking things over with Billy
Donovan and Quin Snyder
Michael we don't know what they're
talking about not at all but it's nice
to see the energy back in the building
here under it been on the road for the
last week here folks and I thought the
hardest part of that road trip now this
is my opinion was the Detroit game
second night up a back-to-back Clippers
you know you know you didn't play a good
game against the Clippers and all of a
sudden you got to hit the road and start
an East Coast Swing in Detroit on the
second night of a back-to-back we're not
really sure if folks we're gonna get
some information for you as soon as we
could find out but clearly game right
now is a little bit of a delay
[Music]
so both head coaches have gone back and
you see the teams heading back to the
locker room
the officials now going over the scores
table
[Music]
and so it appears that we are going to
wait for the announcement is the
officials are giving it to PA announcer
mario nani here inside the arena
confirmation to start the game
[Music]
so there is a long discussion out on the
floor with the officials the head
coaches we still don't know what the
discussion was about so as soon as we
hear anything
we will relay that information to you
ruchi Pat frog still on the headset
all likelihood communicating
with the league cuz there were some
illnesses prior to the game will be
Gobert being one of them and he was
scratched waiting on the league to give
the okay in order to proceed with this
game waiting for the lead to confirm the
greenlight because there were some
illnesses with some players prior to
this game Rudy Gobert was scratched
players were talking amongst themselves
prior to the game and so just waiting to
get the okay essentially from the league
to proceed with tonight's game advance
did unforeseen circumstances the game
tonight has been postponed you are all
safe
[Music]
and take your time and leaving the arena
tonight and do so in an orderly fashion
thank you for coming out tonight we are
all safe and you can visit OKC Thunder
calm for updates on upcoming games
please drive home safely good night fans
[Applause]
bite on this game and the official
announcement just came that this game
has been postponed so any further
information will have to come later on
that is all the information that we have
right now that has been disseminated
from the league to us here inside the
arena and so the jazz and thunder will
not play the game here tonight
unfortunately the game has been
postponed we will send it back